[Musique]
bonsoir nous n'allons pas passer le peu
de temps qui nous est imparti dans cette
campagne officielle adressée avec vous
le bilan de monsieur giscard best ce
bilan est désastreux et vous le
connaissez vous travailleuses et
travailleurs parce que vous vivez chaque
jour il faut battre jusqu'à destin et il
faut changer de politique
c'est ce que nous voulons et c'est
possible c'est pourquoi dès hier soir
dans sa première intervention
georges marchais vous l'a annoncé chaque
minute de son temps de parole il va le
consacrer cette unique question la seule
qui compte le changement ce soir il veut
vous vous entretenir vous faire
réfléchir sur la politique économique et
sociale nouvelle qu'il convient
d'appliquer avec philippe herzog
économistes polytechnicien dirigeant
national du parti communiste français
est avec moi même pierre juquin alors si
vous le voulez bien
réfléchissons ensemble pour trouver le
bon remède il faut d'abord définir la
cause du mal
quel est le mal dont souffre la france
pour monsieur giscard d'estaing c'est
toujours le pétrole le pétrole et la
crise internationale georges marchais ça
le pétrole s'est vu c'est une chanson
que les français connaissent bien
puisque giscard la chante depuis sept
ans en duo d'ailleurs avec raymond bas
mais ce n'est pas sérieux
ce n'est pas sérieux le pétrole n'a pas
la responsabilité de la crise que
connaît la société française d'ailleurs
pour s'en convaincre il n'est que de
prendre deux chiffes qui sont très
significatifs par rapport aux richesses
produites
la fracture prête pétrolière se chiffre
aujourd'hui à 4%
en 1974 elle était de trois et demi pour
cent c'est à dire 0,5 pour cent de plus
seulement l'inflation l'inflation en
1980 et de 15% selon à 10 de la cgt le
seul juste et bien dans ces 15% 2 %
reviennent au pétrole et 13%
c'est la facture de monsieur giscard
d'estaing à l'andouille al mal
d'ailleurs je vais encore dire un mot
sur le pétrole
un pays comme l'angleterre possède
d'énormes richesses
les etats unis possèdent d'énormes
richesses pétrolières
or je fais observer que ces deux pays
connaissent à là fois le chômage et
d'inflation
deux millions et demi de chômeurs en
grande bretagne par conséquent il faut
chercher la cause de la crise la société
française ailleurs elle est dans la
course aux profits capitalistes toute la
politique giscardienne depuis sept ans a
été orientée dans un seul but à croire à
croître à croître toujours plus les
profits des multinationales
les profits du patronat français alors
giscard a réussi oui il a réussi
parfaitement
mais d'abord à par quels moyens
ce qu'on appelle nous la casse des
usines le démantèlement autrement et il
est par exemple idées certaines branches
d'industrie que du patronat français
considèrent comme a suffisamment juteuse
ça ne rapporte pas à cette profitent
alors on abandonne on casse des lucides
on abandonne des branches entières de
notre industrie
l'exportation des capitaux à l'étranger
l'exportation des entreprises
on casse des entreprises chez nous on
les en plantes à l'étranger où on peut
explorer exploitée de la main d'oeuvre à
bon marché
donc on voit d'hong kong bahdja pong par
conséquent c'est toujours le profit qui
est à la base de cette politique
alors tu me demandes qu'ils ont réussi
mais bien sûr ils ont réussi en 1979
pour toute l'année
c'est le dernier chiffre connu 470
milliards de profits pour les patrons 47
mille milliards anciens presque
l'équivalent du budget de la france
encore un chif il y a dans ce pays 520
mille familles qui perçoivent chaque
mois un revenu moyen de 7 millions 700
mille anciens francs par conséquent je
dis la course au profit
voilà la cause du madon dont la société
france et ils veulent aller plus loin
ils veulent aller plus loin ils veulent
toujours plus de profits et cela
conduira à une aggravation du chômage
dans les prochaines années si l'on n'y
mettait un terme
j'en donne une preuve le fameux plan
giscard en sept points pour l'emploi il
a fait miroiter la création d'un million
d'emplois
je passe sur le fait qu'il s'agit d'
emplois au rabais intérimaire à temps
partiel mais surtout ce que je veux
démontrer c'est que giscard cache la
vérité les études du 8e plan nos propres
chiffres concordent le million d'emplois
dont il parle il ne compensera même pas
la différence entre tous le nombre de
tous ces jeunes qui vont arriver dans la
vie active dans les prochaines années et
les départs en retraite
d'autre part jyske a à cacher la
suppression d'un million d'emplois
industriels pour le profit qui est
programmée dans montré des chiffres est
programmée dans le viiième plan et
d'autre part bien sûr il ya deux
millions de chômeurs aujourd'hui 2
millions plus 1 million ça fait 3
millions de chômeurs
en 1986 avec giscard et j'en veux pour
preuve pour résumer un graphique issues
d'études officiel ce qui monte ici c'est
le nom de toutes celles et tous ceux qui
veulent du travail les jeunes les femmes
les chômeurs ça ça c'est la réduction
des emplois avec la politique des
patrons pour le profit en 1981 nous
avons deux millions de chômeurs en 1986
cela conduit à plus de 3 millions de
chômeurs et j'insiste non seulement six
jusqu'à reste mais aussi avec tout autre
politique qui ne s'attaquerait pas à la
racine du mal c'est à dire la course au
profit
par conséquent on peut vaincre le mal et
c'est l'objectif central de georges
marchais c'est l'objectif central qu'il
présente dans son livre les sports
présents dans ces tentes cent trente et
une proposition une france sans aucun
chômeur sans aucune chômeuse au plus
tard dans sept ans c'est évidemment un
changement considérable et il faut
prendre le taureau par les cornes
il faut aller au fond des choses tout de
suite avec des mesures massives
importante avec des grands moyens
dès les deux premières années georges
marchais propose de supprimer 1 million
au moins de chômeurs en créant un
million et demi d'emplois comment faire
au bout du septennat je propose trois de
créer 3 million et 3 millions et demi
d'emplois
alors il faut arrêter naturellement
immédiatement la casse dont je parlais
tout à l'heure le démantèlement des
branches industrielles françaises et la
voix dont certaines productions
agricoles j'y reviendrai
et il faut relancer la production
nationale
enfin françaises et français il faut
quand même savoir aujourd'hui par
rapport à 1974
la france elle produit moins d'acier -
de charbon - textile - de
machines-outils moins de bateaux moins
de logements moins d'engrais
voilà la réalité que giscard d'estaing
cash aux françaises et aux français et
je vous le demande
vous n'avez besoin de rien tous vos
besoins sont satisfaits dans tous les
domaines en france
et à l'extérieur de nos frontières
évidemment non par conséquent il faut
relancer la production nationale
relancer la production nationale georges
marchais faut des débouchés le premier
débouché c'est le marché intérieur c'est
à dire la consommation des français et
des habitants en france non d'abord il
ya une première question je pense
auxquelles il faut répondre
est ce que nous avons déjà les avant de
le faire mais parce que nous avons les
atouts
oui nous avons les atouts pour le faire
nous avons des ressources énergétiques
nous avons un potentiel industriel
important nous avons l'une des arts et
cultures les plus riches et les plus
diversifiées du monde en tenant compte à
la fois du climat et du savoir faire de
nos paysans nous avons les sciences et
des techniques
la france à des réalisations de ce point
de vue extraordinaire encore est il que
nos chercheurs ne dispose pas de tous
les moyens dont ils auraient besoin
mais nous avons déjà un potentiel
considérable et enfin nous avons des
hommes parce que la seconde c'est à dire
les hommes et les femmes d'ailleurs
attention les hommes et des femmes
nous avons des millions d'ouvriers
d'ingénieurs de techniciens deux cadres
de savants de jeunes qui ne demandent
qu'à créer autrement dit nous avons les
atouts vos produits alors j'en reviens à
ma question quels débouchés
d'abord le marché intérieur a évidemment
marché intérieur il faut que les
françaises et les français sachent que
1% de consommation en plus et c'est cent
mille emplois créés vous comprenez
pourquoi en vue de relancer la
consommation intérieure je propose le
smic immédiatement à 3300 francs avec
dates respectives de 4000 francs tout de
suite 3003 poursuit 3300 francs
l'augmentation des bas salaires une
augmentation des allocations familiales
sa 500 finlandais premier del promenait
le
premier enfant voilà des mesures
sociales qui permettront d'augmenter la
consommation populaire
j'ajoute qu'il faut relever les
retraites les allocations pour les
handicapés et pour les avanies il ya
tous les besoins collectifs plus où les
besoins collectifs école logement santé
non seulement du point de vue du fond
que de lydie des équipements mais aussi
de mort chaudement il faut que ça tourne
bien tous faut que ça marche
donc ça m'a fait ya besoin de personnel
par mois alors renoncé donc la
consommation intérieure d'abord c'est
une mesure de justice sociale
on parle toujours justice sociale
justice sociale justice locale mais pour
qu'il y ait justice sociale il faut
prendre ces mesures là et en même temps
ce sont des mesures qui permettront la
relance de l'économie face mais alors
est-ce qu'on va fermer les frontières
produisons français consommons français
l'international ceux qui parlent de
reconquête du marché intérieur sans
prendre des mesures pour empêcher
l'invasion de notre économie par des
produits étrangers
eh bien il se moque du monde je dis oui
je dis qu'il faut protéger notre
économie
lorsque il y à des importations abusives
ou encore lorsqu'il s'agit de développer
deux puissantes base industrielle chez
nous lorsqu'elles sont insuffisantes les
américains ils se protègent les japonais
ils se protègent les allemands se
protègent pourquoi pas nous reste la
question de la rentabilité
il faut que nos entreprises et notre
économie soit compétitive juge avant une
nouvelle conception de la rentabilité
sur quoi repose l avant d'abord je veux
dire que du point de vue encore par
rapport ce que vient de dire philippe
rééquilibrer nos échanges rééquilibrer
nos échanges avec des états unis
d'allemagne fédérale et le japon il faut
savoir que le déficit du commerce
extérieur avec ces trois pays nous
coûtera 400 mille emplois en conséquent
faut rééquilibrer nos échanges avec les
pays capitalistes avec les pays
socialistes et avec cet immense
potentiel que représente le tiers monde
nous y reviendrons dans une prochaine
mission parce que je
des frontières non au diktat d'origine
tonnes et non au diktat de bruxelles
alors oui la conception nouvelle de la
productivité parce que nous ne sommes
pas indifférents à cette question il est
évident que pour satisfaire les besoins
des françaises et des français
il faut accroître la production et il
faut accroître la productivité du
travail mais non pas sur le dos des
hommes non pas en rendant de travail
plus difficile pour les hommes
c'est la raison pour lesquelles moi je
considère qu'il faut s'appuyer sur le
progrès scientifique et technique et
nous pouvons le faire
et assurer ainsi un haut niveau de
productivité de charbon qui t'a été
offert par les mineurs de la drêche dans
les cévennes en est un exemple
c'est tout un symbole alors quelles sont
les mesures que je propose de ce point
de vue leur retour à la semaine le
retour aller à ce que nous les amenons
semaine de travail de 35 heures avec
bien entendu le maintien du pouvoir
d'achat du salaire actuel la cinquième
semaine de congés la cinquième équipe et
l'avancement de l'âge de la retraite à
60 ans pour les hommes et à 55 ans pour
les femmes et je dis même moins pour
ceux qui effectuent des travaux pénibles
dans mon livre l'espoir au présent j'ai
fait la démonstration qu'il est des
travailleurs dont l'espérance de vie est
de 9 ans à inférieurs à celles des cas
qui ne touche pas les cotisations qu'ils
ont versé pour leur retraite
c'est une injustice révoltante et alors
la fin des discriminations des cadences
infernales de travail des brimades un
plan d'urgence pour donner un bon métier
aux jeunes
et alors de ce point de vue je dis tout
de suite il faut en finir avec ces
agences d'intérim qui sont les
véritables négriers des temps modernes
il faut que les intérimaires vacataires
stagiaires et je ne sais quoi encore
soit affecté comme des travailleurs nord
montrent une dans des régions et d'une
très grande revendication reste une
question j'attire l'attention sur le
fait que toutes ces mesures permettent à
la fois la production
la productivité du travail et ils créent
des emplois et c'est des mesures de
justice correspondant à l'époque que
nous vivons la justice marche donc avec
la morale absolue et les connaît
l'efficacité mais l'efficacité mais
laisse pas trop beau l'argent
l'inflation comment étant réglé ce
problème j'ai pitié du dana l'argent il
existe je suis le seul candidat a parlé
de cette question
j'ai écouté hier soir sur les dix
candidats y en a assez que prononcer le
mot profit c'est moi ça suffit c'est
devenu maintenant un mot tabou
on ne veut pas en parler ja je viens de
montrer qu' il existe
moi je dis ceci l'austérité l'austérité
je suis pour mais pas toujours pour les
mêmes moi je suis pour l'austérité pour
les riches et pas pour les travailleurs
voilà les raisons pour lesquelles moi je
dis l'argent eh bien il faut prendre là
où il est alors quelles sont ces mesures
s'attaquent sadaka la fois au profit au
gâchis et à la domination du capital
rapidement quelques exemples impôt sur
la fortune a pour sûr la capitale
suppression des cadeaux aux patrons
lutte contre la fuite des capitaux
élimination des spéculations et dépenses
parasitaire à pau sur les hauts revenus
et je redis partout je considère que
ceux qui ont un revenu mensuel supérieur
à 4 millions d'anciens francs au dessus
il faut tout parce que ça rapporte
beaucoup d'argent par exemple cette
dernière cette seule mesure cette seule
mesure au super mignon paroisse on prend
tout ça rapporte 83 milliards de francs
lourd c'est à dire de quoi financer la
création de 800 mille emplois
supplémentaires c'est considérable de
l'argent il y en a de l'argent il y en a
il suffit de s'attaquer aux profits et
alors les moyens pour cela
eh bien ce sont liés les mesures
démocratiques et anticapitalistes qui
sont proposés dans mon plan jeudi il
faut nationaliser les banques et du
trading
et les principes autre os analystes ont
figuré nationalisation c'est décisif
c'est très important
c'est capital fonds lv font enlever le
pouvoir
gilles brad
absolument à ce qu'ils font la casse
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure il faut
décentraliser d'état le décentraliser il
faut faire reculer la bureaucratie
voilà les l'ensemble des propositions
qui me permettent de lancer à giscard
d'estaing le défi du plein emploi et je
dis que c'est sérieux
ce sont des propositions sérieuses je
veux je veux atteindre cet objectif
mais naturellement c'est à vous de
choisir et bien mesdames messieurs notre
émission de ce soir se termine
georges marchais vous a expliqué dans sa
première intervention hier qu'il y a
trois moyens pour réaliser le changement
nécessaire
le premier moyen c'est une politique
nouvelle avec les objectifs et les
moyens économiques de réaliser ses
objectifs
le deuxième moyen c'est une union
populaire anp rassemblement majoritaire
et un gouvernement d'union socialistes
communistes le troisième moyen ce sont
vos luttes avoue travailleuses et
travailleurs ce soir georges marchais ne
vous a pas fait de promesses il vous a
dit voilà ce qu'il faut faire
on peut le faire faisons le ensemble
demain ou plus exactement vendredi
prochain nouveau rendez-vous à la
télévision où nous poursuivrons cette
réflexion avec emmanuel maffre baugé
député languedocien à l'assemblée
européenne et andré lajoinie député
communiste de l'allier
[Musique]